chéri on a gagné combien aujourd'hui on
a perdu combien aujourd'hui un milliard
de merde
je dois dire que c'est la première fois
que je vois ça de bordel de merde
c'est le truc le plus dingue que j'ai
jamais vu
oh de million de dollars tu vas
en faire quoi t'acheter une Ferrari oh
eh surveille ton langage le petit
écoute là
les amis c'est roaring Kitty je vais
choisir une action et vous expliquer
pourquoi elle est intéressante cette
action c'est
game stop j'adore ce mec
[Applaudissements]
les petits porteurs nous sur GameStop
ils ont l'air de croire que c'est un bon
investissement on dirait qu'il y a un
type qui les oriente vers cet achat
c'est qui ce con
le gourou de l'argent facile je veux
bien ma part
Wall Street Paris que cette boîte va se
planter et si elle se plante ces
connards des fonds de pension vont bien
se goinfrer
70 000 personnes ont vu cette vidéo
je le suis si livage le sud continue son
envolée
un palais allez on traque mon frère est
un de merde Wall Street doit voir
ça non
oh il ferait bien de te connecter
vous avez une minute c'est-à-dire
on a gagné combien aujourd'hui
5 millions on a perdu combien
aujourd'hui un milliard
4 millions
mais vraiment péter dessus
ils vont venir te faire la pauvre on
doit parler du problème GameStop
les petits porteurs perdent toujours
vous êtes assignés
[Musique]
devant le Congrès ça change la donne
le prix plein de gens disent que
le système déconne
l'idée de base c'était kambour c'était
pas con et que tu es un minimum de
chance tu peux faire fortune mais ça ça
marche plus
il y a aucun espoir pour les petits
[Musique]